i was in the
china companies
public street
criminal invention department for 10
years
soldier policeman and now defector
this man says he was an enforcer for the
chinese government first in the army
then working as a detective
i'm from the public security bureau i'm
protecting the regime if you're the
enemy there's no need for any courtesy
he was dispatched to xinjiang where
everyone was treated as the enemy and
there was no need for courtesy
it's reached a state of wartime control
when i got there more than 900 000
people had already been detained for
numerous petty reasons like saying
something wrong
we detained them on orders from the
superiors not on any evidence what kind
of evidence can we have what kind of
evidence does this need
the detective who has to be identified
only by the surname
revealed new details about the alleged
mistreatment of uiga detainees
these images shocked the world
they showed prisoners being unloaded
from a train
jang told sky news that this video most
likely shows prisoners from detention
centers in xinjiang being taken to a
larger central facility in the region
because of the different overalls
they're wearing
we gather them together
put hoods on their head two people
handcuffed together to prevent them from
escaping
but he said that trains were also used
to transport uighurs who traveled to
other parts of china back to xinjiang
and that the conditions they endured
were grim
during the train transportation we don't
give them food they're only allowed
bottle caps to drink water to moisten
their lips
to keep order don't let them go to the
toilet they reach their destinations in
two days
they reach xinjiang
and once held in the re-education camps
even worse was waiting he claims
in cases related to politics
jeopardizing the regime cases involving
overthrowing the regime you're allowed
to beat people it's okay to make them
turn in other people's names
you use various methods to put pressure
two people use sticks to weigh down
their legs tie him up and trample his
arm shackle their hands pour cold water
put a water pipe into his mouth and tie
him up and other unique favorite methods
there are numerous forms if accidents
occur it's normal that some people die
that's just how you get used to saying
it please don't blame me
how to say under this kind of management
in the re-education center
beating somebody to death for sure
happens
sky news is not able to independently
verify zhang's account although he has
provided extensive documentation
sky news put jiang's allegations to the
chinese government at a press conference
in beijing
it's forbidden to insult or treat
students at the training center badly by
any means
the things said by the so-called local
policemen could not happen
does not agree with that
they don't see ordinary people as human
beings they do things that you don't do
to human beings jung did some of those
things too he must live with that
but no longer part of the system he is
denouncing it
tom cheshire sky news beijing